rescue crews in Indonesia are racing to
find survivors after a devastating pair
of natural disasters killed about 850
people a powerful 7.5 magnitude
earthquake struck the island of Sulawesi
Friday had triggered a tsunami that
devastated coastal communities hundreds
of people are hurt or missing including
many who are believed to be buried in
mud in Pulu tens of thousands are
homeless Ben Tracy is in Indonesia and
traveling to the hardest hit areas good
morning the death toll here is still
expected to climb and that's because it
has been extremely difficult for
rescuers to get into some of these areas
that were hardest hit and where they
fear many people have died trapped by
rubble and surrounded by mud this woman
spent more than 48 hours waiting for
rescue one of over a million Indonesians
impacted by Friday's earthquake cell
phone video shows the quakes power as
the ground cracks and explodes the earth
rising and falling like waves the
seismic shock also triggered a tsunami
bringing a wall of water nearly 20 feet
high roaring over the island of Sulawesi
it came without warning after the
earthquake cut power to the tsunami
alert system the twin disasters
devastated this city of Palo where
crowded buildings like mosques and malls
collapsed trapping people inside until
Sunday night cries for help could be
heard from the rubble of the roarr roarr
hotel where officials believe 50 people
could be buried under the debris while
some crews are still racing to save
survivors others have turned to the grim
task of collecting bodies the disaster
has left nearly 50 thousand Indonesians
homeless and in care of the military
while surveying the devastation the
Indonesian president told survivors
recovery efforts will take time we
didn't expect it to be like this he said
so we hope and pray for the communities
and be patient a lack of heavy machinery
in these coastal areas is slowing
efforts to remove rubble and potentially
save lives meanwhile 1200 prisoners have
escaped from three different prisons
that were
rocked by this earthquake authorities
are so focused on the search-and-rescue
operation they don't have time to try to
track them down for CBS this morning
then tracy Makassar indonesia